this is i think one of the when you
actually look at the customer
acquisition cost a lot of times founders
tell me yeah we our customer acquisition
crosses 40 and the lifetime value is 10
000. and i'm like how much money you
have in the bank and like we have 300
000 i'm like immediately spend 100 000
and get more customers and they're like
yeah and i'm like what's the hesitation
you should what did you spend last month
do you spend 2 000 last month why not
spend 50 000 a month yeah and i see that
hesitation i realize okay maybe there's
something wrong here with the cap
and then it turns out let's just take a
little hypothetical early stage example
here they have a thousand customers they
spend a hundred thousand on facebook and
google ads to get them
hundred dollars a customer
but they hired an agency to do the work
and they've got a cmo and the cmo has
two people working for them so they
actually spend four hundred thousand
dollars and it's a four hundred dollar
acquisition cost they just left out 75
of the cost because they just took the
number that they spent on google and
facebook and none of the other
associated costs
and that's where people get themselves
in trouble you're totally right also
sometimes if someone wasn't being honest
they might forget to factor in the churn
right right so they're kind of how many
people left every month yeah exactly
they might be in year one of this
acquisition strategy and so they
actually don't have great data on what
the churn's actually going to be and so
they make an estimate and they kind of
like understate the churn which then
overstates the long-term value so you
get the overstated long-term value yes
understated cost acquisition and you've
got on paper looks like the greatest
company of all time
but but under the hood it's not as
strong as you might think it's basically
like people are giving themselves credit
um you know in some places and then
taking out the cost in other places and
you do that three or four times for 10
20 percent each and the stuff
compounding and it's a completely
different looking business and you get a
savvy investor like myself who has been
through you know tens of thousands of
these conversations and has 300
investments and reads the monthly
updates and you're just going to hit a
wall when you hit the savvy investors
because
and then the ones who are even beyond me
i have a diligence team but there are
some places that have associates
who just build business models and
they're going to go in there and then
tell you
these people don't know what they're
doing so either you're going to look
again incompetent
or you're going to look like you're
lying these are the two worst places to
be
as a founder i'm sorry and we're
dwelling on the negative side
but the positive side is if you have
these metrics dialed in
and you're updating it every month
yeah and if they have coffee with you
and everything's dialed in i mean how
impressive is it to you if an hour after
you've had coffee with someone they send
the whole financial package they send
the ltv cac they send the business plan
and you can make a decision right there
it's amazing beautiful beautiful i mean
that is the upside right we're talking
about the downside a lot but there's a
super upside to having this stuff be
tight be conservative
or even have an open conversation of it
hey listen our tax very low right now we
think that's because you know there's a
gap in the market there's not a lot of
competitors it's a new product um and we
don't know our churns so the cac's
certainly going to go up if we take out
that churn uh if we define our ideal
customer as somebody who uses superhuman
for more than a year and so the lucky
lose will be gone you know the the
people who are window shopping will be
gone they're just testing the product
and so we've really got to think that
through man your credibility goes up
another thing i see that kills
credibility
is when founders are doing self dealing
oh god yeah this is to me
and listen i'll be totally honest when i
was starting my career
as a magazine publisher i didn't pay
myself and i just took a draw when i
needed money so
i didn't know how accounting worked i
had a bank of america account for my
company had a bank of america for me
if i ran out of money i would just
wire myself some money i didn't know how
to do anything it was just a company of
one and then i finally got an accounting
was like hey dummy
pay tax payroll tax on that
payroll provider yeah kind of break and
i was like oh how do we clean that up so
there i was cleaning it up um but let's
talk about the self dealing issue what
have you seen what are the big big
no-nos
the biggest one is the one you talked
about which is kind of feeling like
um it's one thing to do all this stuff
um when you're bootstrapping and kind of
getting going but once you've raised
that vc money or angel money from
someone like you you are a fiduciary
there is no self-dealing that is legal
it's illegal it's it's you know you go
to jail for this kind of stuff the first
one is like oh i need to make i'm not
paying myself so i got to give myself a
little bit of cash this month and like
you said they forget to run payroll
taxes through it the board probably
didn't authorize it and they go down
this path of
tons of irs notifications penalties all
this kind of stuff for the payroll tax
problems but more importantly they've
broken the trust with someone like you
yeah when they could have just paid
themselves out of the gate and no one
would have had a problem with it the
second one is
it's kind of sad but sometimes people
think like this is my company it's my
money and so they use the credit card
for their own stuff right and we've had
some unfortunate moments where we've
actually had to like
report
a founder to a board because with like
hey
this person is not buying poker chips
yeah yeah or hotels trip club accounting
clothes whatever yeah these guys all of
a sudden it's like yeah you really can't
go to scores and buy funny money like
what are you doing
like it's not 1990